every Thursday we highlight stories
affecting consumers and this morning
we're focusing on a medical consumer
story more than a million babies have
been born in the u.s. through in vitro
fertilization now a California couple is
suing a fertility clinic that mistakenly
implanted their embryo into another
woman a stranger in New York carried and
gave birth to their son without their
knowledge
Jamie yuccas spoke to the couple and is
in Los Angeles Jamie when did they
realize what happened
well good morning Anthony they realized
at last April when a representative from
cha fertility center called the couple
and asked for a DNA sample one day later
they learned that they had a son born to
a different woman across the country I
didn't get to hold him I didn't get to
have him inside of me I didn't get to
feel him kick and you know those are
bonding moments that I'm never gonna get
but Ani and his shoat Manuka are
grateful for their son alak but
devastated over the moments they missed
I mean sure
hey guys still in shock oh yeah they
claim the mix-up happened when cha
fertility center mistakenly implanted
their embryo as well as the embryo of
another couple into a woman living in
New York City the two babies were born
March 31st to an Asian couple who
thought they were having twins today
they were born they had apparently
called cha and told them okay we're agen
and these children are white they're
Caucasian
these children are definitely not ours
the manukan say they were then asked by
the fertility clinic to submit their DNA
the next day a company representative
told them they had a son she said think
of it as a good thing you have a son now
and then I just like like burst out like
I just lashed out what about the the
woman you know what is she going through
right now
the mannequins endured a court fight to
gain custody of their son the other baby
born to the New York couple was also
returned to his biological parents
we're told us you know no I guess you're
ever gonna be able to get it back we
just just sat there and just looked at
each other and cried all day because we
didn't know on Wednesday the mannequins
filed a lawsuit against cha health
systems with accusations that include
breach of contract medical malpractice
and fraud the anonymous New York couple
is also suing in a separate lawsuit this
is just a failure of epic proportions
Adam Wolfe is the manikins attorney I
can't see how they could ever trust you
again
what we hope happens through this is
that there's not only just compensation
but accountability for cha and an
understanding this will never ever ever
happen again
chop with my family through a living
hell cha has not responded to a repeated
request for comment over three months
after the surprise birth the mannequins
are now bonding with their new son how
does he seem to be doing what the two is
doing great he's smiling he's rolling
over our kids are the light of our lives
the manikins attorney told me that three
different women all had embryos
implanted on the same day last August
including Ani and that New York City
woman now while on ease did not result
in a pregnancy
we're told the embryo that was implanted
inside of her was from a stranger
Anthony well that's just an infuriating
story Jamie thank you very much